hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful
well you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well temperance do
we use that word much in our culture so
easily that one is that one that we use
when we're talking about things you
should do what do you eat in moderation
what's up drink yeah we've actually like
started to require alcohol on the
sellers to you know have a little
display or at the end you should drink
in moderation so they're trying to sell
on TV
after showing people just like partying
or their hearts out they're gonna say
yeah no don't drink quite so much as
these guys right there's a reason for
that now moderation in the sense of
Aristotle's talking what this concerns
with bodily pleasures and it's very very
specific as a matter of fact I think
that what in order to make this work we
want to deviate from Aristotle and
that's in fact immoral theorists who
have used here are some of them at
Thomas Aquinas for example Aristotle
will actually go so far as to say well
it's not just any any bodily pleasure
that accounts its pleasures primarily a
feast and touch and really not so much
of taste and much more of so think about
eating food right when somebody needs
food there is something to this when
somebody eats food if they eat too much
typically it may be because they
actually be too fast and there's sort of
stuffing themselves sort of filling
themselves and you can you give them for
tasting food and they'll eat at just as
much as those good tasting food right
Arizona might be on to something
but it's impossible especially in our
society you know Aristotle didn't didn't
I think conceived at the time when any
kind of food you could possibly want is
available to you pretty readily and a
high level of development almost
anywhere you go this in this nation may
be tasty actually does figure as well
and maybe some other pleasures now what
are other pleasures of touch he talks
about about the pleasures you know
involving sex and he also actually says
explicitly I'm not talking about touch
like you know
go to the public baths the Greeks of the
Romans have public baths where you'd go
in the water and the water was nice to
be in because it was often heated you
know it's nice to take a hot bath right
these weren't people who being
necessarily every day so you know it's
nice anyway and then they have like oil
that was put on them and they'd often
get a massage on that too they they
actually put out so much oil so much
olive oil they had sprinklers to scrape
the excess oil off of them yeah it was
just so think about like going to the
spa
that's really what he's talking about
can you tea too indulgent self-indulgent
with with that or can that be a matter
of moderation I think in our society to
make sense the time need them sleep I
think that could fit in here as well you
could sleep too much and deprive
yourself too much of sleep just the
right amount
and Aristotle is going to propose a
couple of licenses so what's too much
and what's too little a few says this is
interesting he says we don't really have
a name for this because it's more rare
it's harder to find I wonder if I'm in
our society that's still the same case
he calls with something like means why
there's something like a inability to
enjoy
I think we could probably also think of
some people who willingly deprive
themselves with pleasures and they
almost kind of get a kick out of that
they they try to make themselves eat the
cheapest stuff they can and and you know
if they can just force themselves to do
all these different things maybe you
know I'm not sleep enough that it feels
like they're in charge of themselves so
maybe that would be over on the other
extreme cetera so that would not be a
matter of temperance because the
temperate person actually does enjoy
things you know eros levels nah can t
pleasure he's not saying don't enjoy
yourself at all you saying that this
person here in this metal they desire
Pleasant things to the right amount they
desire Pleasant things the way that they
want to and so what kind of the Pleasant
things do do they desire what it says
when it comes to the natural Pleasant
that's where are the things we find the
actuated plus we don't have to be talked
to in doing these kind of things yeah
there's some small to be life and
there's some we don't
all right there if you actually come to
like repugnant smells it's because
you've probably like gotten used to it
train yourself you know like you know
for me it's kind of silly but most
people don't like the smell of diesel
you know not know the fuel by itself but
like the exhaust I like it kind of for a
stupid reason it reminds me of my
military days because now that's a dumb
reason to like that's not and most
people don't like that smell right you
don't want to watch
yeah what are smells you like think
about the candles at Salamis you know
that's that's one way to tell what
smells people like people like pine
trees people like cookie dough the light
lavender and vanilla things like that
right how do you know those candles so
particularly well you're not going to
find a lot of candles for you know cat
litter all right yeah I hope because
there are certain things that we'd
actually like what about food there's
other foods that we you know in general
as human beings tend to like to eat and
then things as we tend to be kind of
turned off what are we like what you
know what makes food taste good
think about what two components Oh
actually I should say three components
yeah salt sugar and what do you need to
sort of like keep everything you know
it's the vehicle for things we have too
much of it in a lot of our food yeah
yeah now we like these things can you
have too much salt yeah we had a way to
my shirt without the stuff that we eat
that's because we like the taste of
sugar with like sweet brains
if it's not sugar it'll be fat this is
what makes things
so you know those good fats and bad fats
we want to get into all the diet packs
for that sort of thing
this person was actually gonna like
those things but they'd like them to the
right amount they don't have a mastery
over this person with the self-indulgent
person the pleasures master them they
the pleasures make them you know make
the choices that they do and they will
take too much of them they don't have a
good cutoff point when they do cut it
off it's not going to be because they
actually recognize it's a good thing to
be saw control it'll be because somebody
else forces them when it comes to all
these other kinds of pleasures this
person enjoys them to the right amounts
they enjoy the right types of pleasures
they enjoy them in the right way think
about people who are really really
hungry this is kind of an extraordinary
case you put a meal in front of them
what do they do they scarf it up right
we have all sorts of you know terms for
this right and that's interesting to
notice you can find look at every
language there are terms for this sort
of thing you know in German there's
there's Essen impressive press it was
like you know shove everything in your
face now you're not really that hungry
should you be shoving everything into
your face that would probably be a sign
that you're over here this person enjoys
things in the right way you could put
stuff in front of them and if everybody
isn't seated and everybody doesn't have
their meal maybe they can hold on for a
little while and not immediately jump
into their their assault control when it
comes to other pleasant things and
desires the person is soft control
pursues them as they should you know
certain kind of border he says so long
as they don't interfere with their their
hands there are other goals the things
that they value because pleasures are
good right
Lenard bodily pleasures are good too
they can stand in the way of other
things eating too much
a lot of things you'd like to do right
fitting in your clothes for what else
what other goods can interfere with my
help
that's what real good isn't it indulging
yourself too much and eating and
drinking can can interfere with another
thing he says they they don't pursue
pleasures in ways that are contrary to
sort of not just other goods but the
higher goods goods that are acknowledged
as having a certain nobility to them
they also don't pursue pleasures beyond
their means so somebody who is poor is
not going and they are moderate they're
not going to indulge themselves they
really mean suppressed if you here's one
way to it by the way if you're poor and
you're in America on these and you want
to get yourself out of debt you live on
beans and rice because beans and rice
you know they make a protein that you
could you could live on for a long time
there's cheapest is you can come up with
and if you learn how to cook them well
it doesn't take long and learn how to
cook them well it tastes okay you know
you don't have to live on it's all this
guy has to live up beats all the time
what about when it comes to to sex oh
yeah these for moderate do we naturally
desire sex yeah I mean there are some
people who are asexual who apparently
don't have any sort of sexual desire but
that's usually seen as something there's
something wrong with you know great
chemistry or perhaps organically they
may actually be when the aerosol falls
in sensible appreciation
if you indulge yourself in sexual
desires can that the problem what would
be the extreme what do we call yeah sex
essence right people who simply cannot
keep themselves from engaging in sexual
behavior no matter what the context is
there are some context where you
shouldn't be
you shouldn't be not even just like not
having sex there's some context words
have been appropriate even to like flirt
the song right would you say the person
who is over on this really really far at
this extreme condemned aterna dog that's
a very dangerous way to be is imagine
not being able to control yourself so
here's a little doesn't think that way
so if you look here here here well
oftentimes
but this is a good one to think about as
well so now remember this person who's
over here they do feel pleasure they
desire pleasure they desire it to the
right amount and when it comes to snacks
that's probably you know naturally a
fairly high amount but they don't
indulge themselves in ways that actually
contravene other goods for them would be
other goods indulging yourself sexually
it's correct
we talk about health right can you be
kind of risky to my face off with that
sort of thing yeah what else top very
very good that's that's really a key
thing if you want to be in a committed
relationship unless it's you know a very
open relationship which is there may be
problems with that in commitment right
maybe there's an intrinsic disconnect
there
you can't just indulge yourself in any
way you want to okay
you can't even adult yourself any way
you want to with that person with whom
in your in the relationship because if
you only treat them as a sex object
yeah something to satisfy your desires
after a while they're going to start
complaining aren't they they're gonna
say this isn't a relationship this is
just you know this is just hooking up so
if you want certain goods you can't be
dunking or so you guys are college
students to think about some other goods
that are guaranteed to you by being
temperate that if your goods that are
that would be the opposite I'd be like
you know stuff that would be salted oh
yeah I mean you could actually say yeah
I want to be I know but I you know be
sexually promiscuous because they have
allowed me to have a better you know
access to drugs but some folks just
extinct you what what a pleasure for
another right what are you guys trying
to do here in college yeah learn okay so
can you indulge yourself as much as you
like and actually learn anything no I
made some people go to college and
that's all they do and then they come
out there and they actually learned
anything
I'm actually graduate you have to have
some self control you have to have some
reporting some sense of being in charge
of your own desires and here if you're
enjoying it - pleasures before you can't
progress it's not just learning to get
you here for - right what else can get
one-on-one at your college and it's a
good yeah you don't want the piece of
paper do you want the job right human
you don't just love a job because you
guys could have those you guys want a
career you want something fulfilling for
you
and again if you that moderation if you
indulge yourself in whatever pleasures
you want to you place that good of a
pleasure above the good of having the
career they're incompatible to
circumstance I suppose there could be
some careers where maybe it would be
possible to indulge yourself quite a bit
but anyway even chefs
if you're a liquor salesman
you couldn't just drink all the time
could you and be a good liquor salesman
so yeah so there's even with that
there's what about this end
aerosol debuff there's very few people
like this what do you guys think are
there people who don't take enough
pleasure who are sort of anti pleasure
they're not really
whenever ladies you know self-control or
moderate they just don't enjoy things
yeah
I think that's exactly and again
there's there certain gaps aerosol
because of his culture and because of
his position in this culture there are
certain experiences that he did
encounter very well but I think yet we
in our culture we have a lot of people
who actually like swing from one extreme
to the other
you know unworthy of having legitimate
pleasure the pleasure that this person
enjoys and so they you know they're very
rigorous very ascetic and then suddenly
they go off the wagon and what they do
that's like you know there are no rules
anymore for at least a little while and
then then they start feeling bad about
that and I'm actually back here people
do this with food people do this with
drinking people do this with drugs
people do this with sexuality I don't
know too many people who do this with
sleeping but maybe there's something
we're doing sleeping some people deal
with indulgence of other bodily desires
and pleasures so you have to get right